je te remercie d'être là parce que
j'imagine que c'était pas pareil on
reçoit j'aime beaucoup ça j'aime pas
beaucoup ça a été le choc c'est un
miroir déformant et un peu pénalisant je
sais c'est pas très bien trop la honte a
dit que quand on était dans une telle
est en train de vendre le disent de
faire la promo d'un 10 on avait
l'impression un peu d'être un vrp que sa
camionnette garée en tout six lois c'est
sûr que c'est incontournable
ou quand on venait benso on a envie de
faire connaître aux fins de faire
partager le plaisir quand ils veulent
faire avec c'est andy moyens de pouvoir
le faire connaître quoi ces troubles et
tu crois qu'être star c'est se faire
rare probablement en tout cas éviter
vite et de lasser les gens ouais parce
que c'est enfin c'est tout le système un
petit peu mongolien et qu'on voit trop
les gens et qu'on est là c'est que ça va
trop vite
ouais t'as peur de lover explosion
recommandé quoi où et puis en plus ça ne
correspond pas vraiment ouais tu te
discret comme make way je préfère porter
un clic-clac est génial il sort en fin
de semaine on va pas dire son nom parce
que il est polonais ils viennent une
fois ici chapelle speaks during this
program on appelle ce bijou d'un génie
c'est jacques store c'est un mec qui
qui est le seul en fait à utiliser un
système nouveau au monde qui permet
d'avoir plusieurs générations d'image
ils ont sans perdre en qualité
donc ça lui permettent toutes les
fantaisies possible en font du doigt le
but de lennon qui est pour marcher
dehors entre autres celui de lou reed
là il fait plein de cris pour plein de
gens qui l'avaient dit j'arrête de faire
des clips
il ya deux ans entre stars qui lui avait
demandé we madonna
cindy lauper de gens il n'a pas voulu il
n'a pas voulu que c'est quelqu'un qui
vont comparaître est resté aux états
unis mais qui a besoin de travailler
avec des gens dont ils considèrent
qu'ils ont des messins peut on se passer
un message avec mes messages de
personnel mais en tout cas dans la
musique lui a trouvé qu'il avait un
message d'amour cleanova une espèce de
4,5 il a séduit c'est un peu un rêve
une forte comme ça pour dire la messe
avec twente et leslie djhone est parti
on s'est rencontrés dans l'avion
mais si tu l'a rencontré dans l'avion
ait pas plus de facilité suivi bon c'est
subi pendant six heures
ouais c'est le meilleur disquaires du
monde avant peut être un accent breton
va faire le blind test on va y aller
alors c'est ça l'idée que c'est pas ce
lundi c'est ce qui se fait dans la
presse depuis 30 ans mais c'est la
première fois que la télé donc il est
passé un disque d'avoir faut qu'il
reconnaisse qu'ensuite tout une dizaine
c'était moche alors à toi sur le premier
c'est pas très dur fonctionne pas et
bien vous allez on sait pas trop si le
soir
ah bah voyons
avec moi c'est le marine
on a assez le mari s'est entraîné
aujourd'hui way la meinau crocs et 68
bravo mais pas jaloux d'une fronde qui
soit copains et françoise hardy comme ça
bon jusqu'au port de tunis avant tout
autant avec le petit aussi coûté la vie
de la famille tu vas manger de dimanche
elle me dit c'est ça serait bon allez la
suisse à s'être laissés amour amour
toujours mascaret deuxième morceau un
peu plus vieux
voilà c'est ce que je sais c'est sur un
album des beatles qui s'appelle l'art it
is
il ya quelques trucs pas mal
c'est ce qui m'a étonné c'est pas parce
qu'on est hostile au canada et recoller
les beach boys
ça s'appelle du yo-yo ma et ça devait
être une face b de l'été de vie en
soixante dix et puis ça l'a jamais fait
ça les vaut tous les littoraux des
citrons comme les beatles c'est quoi les
beatles mais bronson ouest c'est toute
une époque où j'essaie de l'infiltré
dans les boums et qu on me jetait tout
le temps et coûte talons parce que
j'étais un tee shirt
c'est même un caractère moment mais ça
me plaisait déjà de participer bout mais
que cela nous y essayer de machines très
dans le monde y est on vraiment ils ont
changé complètement ma vie est ce que
toi ils ont une influence aussi
importante sur la toile j'ai raté mes
études à cause des noms mais cette fois
je le préférais les stones du valais peu
avant l'été stone plus tôt mais non ce
qui a vraiment changé d'avis et aux
sites barrés
en prêt à monaco c'était plus le choc
disent que suivre alors attention là
c'est patchouli c'est un peu dur en fait
c'est toujours c'est pas très loin des
beatles son plus récent disque apple
dans son rapport à capitaux sur soi
ouais parce qu'il valait rondelle quand
même sa seigneurie
c'est ça mais le loc tous non c'est
encore plus jeune je suis encore plus
bas ben c'est du coup ravi shankar il
était président de george harrison
c'était dans les années 75 mais mieux
jouer et c'est vrai qu'à une époque où
les beatles ou rick la terre une chanson
dans ton dernier
33 tours qui s'appelera bout c'est
plutôt j'ai eu une période riche en
quinze jours c'est pas très longtemps
mais pas longtemps je crois qu'on est
dans un mouvement pact toubab à la
trempe de toute façon s'il est si j'en
ai vu le cancer de prudence mais
derrière il ya des moments c'est
carrément d'offrir au témiscouata
73 72
après 65 pop psychédélique que tu veux
que je pense qu'on va ressortir les
pattes d'eph bien dans les a déjà
rochelle régit les enfants ont déjà
ressenti brillante on enfin je veux dire
à un niveau plus doux plus beaucoup plus
visible et populaire quartiers suivants
disque sur un an atteint celui là l'est
pas c'est bon c'est pas un seul de ses
six essais quand c'est le rôle des miros
façon c'est en chanson c'est exprès soit
il faisait quoi bon 77 gt gt à l'eau et
puis je sais ma filtré ici aussi c'est
très visuel efforts c'est une embellie
et jacno politiken
mais si mes potes important c'est la
première vraie révolution
les jeunes que j'ai pu me connaître
j'étais à fond à fond la caisse dans
plus musicalement que que
vestimentairement parlant j'ai pas pris
une fin
on attaque lors je suis allé au suivant
je suis là il va trouver aussi parce
qu'il aurait aimé ça à ce qu'on peut
dire déjà c'est que c'est le générique
de l'union a produit blanche parce que
l'année dernière tout le monde nous a
dit pendant alan shepard generis cette
année c'est toi qui veux dire je suis un
peu spéciaux qui dure une demi-heure
je suis donc un peu plus loin
enfin ça c'est la partie dépendante
génériques en plus
c'est fort et l'effort c'est vrai qu'il
est très fort c'est quoi ces visiteuses
ouais c'est dans une bonne dynamique
reding je rentrais pas fait ça riait
tout une partie où il chante tout seul
après chantal oui on a pris à bail qui
arrive à 77 alors à la même époque y
avait des gens qui avaient pas du tout
le même trip c'est parce que c'est aussi
la naissance de notre mouvement parce
que ce qu'ils en pensent de ça aussi ça
c'est le palace ouais
le fort tu connais une en europe
michael zegen ça ressort de voyenne
reddition maintenant il ya toute une
reddition de youtube discours des années
77 78 c'est bien parce que c'est des
trucs qu'il faut avoir très grave reste
à gérer
moi je trouve que c'est pas ces pages et
dans toute la semaine vraiment c'était
vraiment l'archétype ce qui les met pas
au deuxième degré je veux dire
angeleo c'est pas mal alors là et on va
le prochain je le mets ça sur lyon
nantes ou quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sap a été un succès 1
c'est très confidentielle très en dedans
c'est pas rien adjani sachent que ce
n'est pas parce qu'on n'est pas sans
cesse au petit oiseau sur une chanson
chez lui au bataillon mais je
connaissais l'album avec gainsbourg
crois que c'est le disque la presse et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux